first he was a sexist than a racist than
a Nazi literally Hitler reborn now he's
a traitor to his country the left has
run out of possible verbal attacks on
President Trump there none left all
that's left is violence and some on the
Left appear to be encouraging that
progressives have graduated from
rhetoric to physical action for example
congressional candidate Alexandria
Acacio Cortes is calling on progressives
to occupy airports and ice offices to
shut down immigration enforcement and
keep people from doing their jobs and
people from flying on airplanes for that
matter
former Hillary Clinton aide Philippe
Raines who was just in a previous
segment has brought airhorns to the
White House in an attempt to keep the
president and his family from sleeping
congressman Maxine Waters of Los Angeles
wants Trump administration officials
harassed or if they dare go out into
public and plenty of regular people seem
to be on board with that that shouldn't
surprise you they have been told for
months by the press and by progressive
leaders that the president is a Nazi
secret agent working for our greatest
enemy of Vladimir Putin if you really
believe that what wouldn't you do why
wouldn't use violence to save your
country you probably would things might
get worse from here the weather is
getting hotter we've got six weeks to go
until September the midterms are getting
closer harassment and occupation could
easily turn into something far worse you
know what we're talking about people are
being primed for that and the left is
recklessly egging it on and they're not
even doing it on behalf of the interests
of Americans but literally for the sake
of foreigners the Montenegrins you must
be ready to die for for some reason the
illegal immigrants who apparently now
have a god-given right to enter this
country nobody in the left is occupying
Purdue Pharma to protest the opioid
epidemic the tens of thousands of people
killed by opioids last year we're mostly
born in America they don't help big
business or get Democrats elected so
they don't matter
congressman Aaron swallow up a sense
California he joins us tonight
congressman what's the penalty for
treason Tucker a good evening you know
that the the penalty that we are all
paying right now for the president's
treason is we are losing our allies we
see a wrecking ball
threatening our freedoms here at home
and by the president's own definition of
treason Tucker let's just use that
Sirica what's what's your definition of
treason I know we're a trail betrayal of
the American people but treason its
reasons a capitalist why doesn't this
definition matter he's the president he
said that down I'm asking I'm telling
you he's the president he said Democrats
committed treason when we didn't stand
up for him at the State of the Union
conduct in hell was beyond that his
treason is treason so treason is
punishable by death it's an actual crime
and I think you're an attorney you would
know that so when you tell your
constituents that the President of the
United States has committed a
death-penalty offense are you concerned
that maybe just possibly you're torquing
up the rhetoric past the point of
reasonable conversation no I'm saying
that the president by its own definition
don't president I want to know what you
think you're accusing the president of a
capital offense why wouldn't it be more
useful for the rest of us to explain
specifically the policies that you
disagree with and we can have a debate
on them if you think the United States
has an obligation to defend NATO members
tell us why instead he's a treasonous
Nazi you think it's up for oh I didn't
call him a Nazi Tucker but why don't you
have a problem that the president United
States wants to turn over a innocent US
ambassador to the Russians that don't
you have a project do we draw a line
somewhere do we want to hear my
transcript with a lot of things the
president has said I'm asking you who is
you before the people accusing the
president of treason if that's helpful
yeah I mean is that the kind of rhetoric
again is an elected official - you think
Spurs thoughtful constructive
conversation that brings the country
together or doesn't whip the morons into
a frenzy and increase the likelihood of
violence well honestly give me a real
answer yeah I think this is a beautiful
country that has always added freedoms
and we have a wreckingball president
right now don't give me these words
like the answer you may not like the
answer but it's just I mean working with
an enemy Russia's economy what we're
done is that there's not really so every
president home is not sharing I'm
kidding trees and who went over to
Helsinki had a private meeting agreed to
turn over a US ambassador to an enemy
and sided with them over our own
Intelligence Committee at what point do
you draw a line and say that's not a
u.s. president okay it's just the Prime
Minister of Russia defending the
President of Russia what she didn't the
president is more loyal to Russia than
the I mean you're a member of Congress
you're not allowed to talk like a child
or make reference accusations no I'm
just shocked that you're talking like
this do you want it to be led by
somebody who is sorry I love Russian
tree over the United States and I'm
older than you are don't call into
question my love of the country come on
now please private conversation with a
dictator agreed to turn over a US
ambassador it's just when you just stop
for one second yeah you think it is
treasonous for an American president to
meet privately with the head of state
who we don't get along with is that what
you're saying I think it's a betrayal of
the United States to side with Russia
over our own intelligence community to
agree to turn over a US ambassador to
Russia who is innocent knowing what the
president should the president meet with
the leader of China obviously a
dictatorship kills its political enemies
practices censorship actually is a great
deal of censorship it inflicts on
American companies should he meet with
the Chinese premier or would that be
treason as well if we're gonna get
something out of it we didn't get
anything because a lot of your
constituents get money from China as we
know I mean you represent the Bay Area
try to pumps a lot of money you know
don't insult the Bay Area just I'm
noting a fact which is China makes a lot
of your constituents rich Chinese are
more repressive country than Russia
Russia doesn't censor the internet the
way that China does
we'll just be real all the freedom stuff
does it mean Cu does it know if let's
focus on the country that attacked us
and the president who met with that
dictator right after those indictments
came with meeting with the Saudis they
behead people they kill gays you ok with
that they don't let women drive up and
so recently that's okay with you though
I think I see why you want to distract
from rules are here Tucker
tell me what you're ok with it tell me
why you were ok with what the president
did yesterday because I meeting with
Putin because Putin is one of those
leaders in the world are you terribly
are you what he said that he sided with
Putin are you okay with that he is
skeptical of intelligence reports just
laying there Konami [ __ ] don't give me
the talk at the talking points Tucker
the son you okay with pants how I feel I
am with Russia will you okay with them
siding with Russia
I'm never okay with an American official
siding with the foreign government over
our own are you okay
with American leaders meeting with heads
of state we disagree with greater if you
met with the Saudis or the Chinese or
indeed with Putin I would like to
interview Putin does that make me a
traitor what about turning over
ambassador McFaul to the Russians what
do you think about that they didn't deny
that today at the press conference that
is so disturbing or do you have a pinion
on that okay yeah I'm sorry sounds like
you know we've got a time for DNC top
urge you to stop using the term treason
because I think it's mindless and I'm
using this president's definition just
the president's definition yeah okay
Thank You congressman good to see you my
pleasure